I grew up drawing my whole entire life
figure drawing primarily and I would say
my junior year in college is when I
actually started painting I seriously I
immediately shifted into using
unconventional materials I started using
objects from my own childhood things
with a certain luster or polished to
them I'm thinking back on china cabinets
and these little beautiful encrusted
plates creating that fiction of glamor
of decadence of wealth I think is
something that's heavily ingrained into
drag culture that it always fascinates
me but it's also heavily ingrained into
black culture looking at you know that
even in certain places where I went to
school growing a lot of people felt the
importance of wearing gold chains a ton
of jewelry or you know the sort of like
young women wearing bamboo gold hoop
earrings with their names scrawled in
them and those types of things to me all
kind of conflate into wanting or
desiring to appear much more than one
maybe feels that they are or deserve to
be
even as a child I would very rarely go
to the barbershop actually I never felt
welcome in that space I always felt like
I was too effeminate or I wasn't used to
being around so many hyper masculine men
and painting myself and sit still the
largest painting that I made an entire
series there's actually the barbers
hands who is always anonymous and every
one of those paintings those barbers
hands come in with a knife for shaving
my neck my head is tilted upwards and so
that kind of tension of yes this
fictional space might be beautiful and
welcoming and exciting and fun and
playful and light-hearted but it is in
reality still unreasonable to envision
me entering that space and feeling fully
safe even now the Warhol Museum is this
how I see at this perfect place for
jebin to have his first solo show it
just connects to a history for German
history of painting and Devon's work
brings Warhol's work to life after a lot
of conversations with jebin about this
body of work and Warhol's practice Deven
started this new body of work around
trans women and drag queens and
specifically a drag queen in Miami that
he met Miss Toto so that painting will
be situated within Warhol's paintings of
from this series from the ladies and
gentlemen series I think the most
important thing for me in this
exhibition is that people leave with a
new image of what race can look like you
know he is working in a long history of
painters that have come before him that
have brought light to black protagonists
and painting into a Canon that doesn't
necessarily have the black protagonist
is the main figure in painting
what Devin's doing now is creating a
space to also embrace an alternative
perspective on that race so queering of
that identity bringing in the feminine
not actually positioning the masculine
always around
painting the flash in different colors
there's a painting called butterfly
eater in which the flash of the figure
takes on the crimson sunset so really
challenging and complicating our ideas
around race and identity in a really
productive way
[Music]
you